[Music]
the process of me getting attracted to
design must have happened over a period
of time I don't recall there having been
a Eureka moment where I decided that I
wanted to go into the design world and I
chose the design option because I
thought through engineering and design
one could create new things be
innovative and do the things that are
into the future I believe that the
design process should start from
listening most of us unfortunately start
the design process by thinking designing
or by talking by expressing opinions
when we do that is because we have
already done the thinking on our
previous design and our previous project
and that thinking may not be suitable
and appropriate for the current design
that we do so we must start from the
very beginning for every design process
the structure of Tokyo marine is a very
very sophisticated system it is
noteworthy not only on its structural
meds but also in the way it integrates
with architecture to the point that by
the time the building is finished that
the two disciplines are merged into one
another such that you'd want one
wouldn't know one from the other and
quite a lot of other things that are in
that in that structure makes that one of
my favorites
troika is a is a somewhat taller
building it is the tallest building
there is at 350 stories so what we did
we came up with a structural system
which was about planes those seemingly
impossible sheer walls which are very
very slender and very very thin flat
plates which were spanning very large
span so this destruction was also that
horizontal panes and vertical plates at
the end of the day everything that we
designed we designed with an M user in
mind or for an end user is designed in a
place making a place that people want
that people actually go to and people
use it in the way it was intended now
and into the future
then they have responded they have given
feedback in memory
[Music]